the united states and taiwan have
announced plans to start trade talks in
the fall taipei says it wants to attract
more u.s investment and join
international trade blocs including the
comprehensive and progressive agreement
for trans-pacific partnership the
announcement comes amid rising tensions
with china a recent visit by u.s house
speaker nancy pelosi to the island
democracy drew sharp criticism from
beijing taiwan is the united states
eighth largest trading partner
delivering semiconductor semiconductors
and many other technologies
let's take a closer look at the matter
with dw correspondent seoul sang-han in
taipei so the u.s and taiwan already
share a long-standing trade and
investment relationship why does this
apparently need to be deepened
well first of all for taiwan um
it's something that they have been
waiting for for more than 20 years
although it's called an initiative now
but taiwan believes that will eventually
become a complete fta and taiwan
believes that it will also help
it to pave the way to join cptpp which
they have a fierce competition with
mainland china and for u.s it's uh just
a part of its um strategy indo-pacific
strategy to build new trade orders um we
know that
china is
trying to gain its
importance and its influence in this
region so there's no doubt that this
initiative is aiming at china which
plays an important role in the world's
biggest trade framework recp in which
the united states is not in so working
closely with taiwan is
essentially a tool to compete
strategically with china
so taiwan hoping for a full-fledged free
trade agreement at the end of these
talks here what specifically is in it
for both sides
well there are 11 topics covered um in
in the document that we've seen but most
of the focus are in this conventional
u.s trade talks so i will highlight two
parts here the first one is the trade
facilitation because taiwan's direct
exports to to the us have been
increasing over the past few years and
u.s is now almost the second largest
trading partner for taiwan so being able
to trade smoothly is
important for the two parts and the
second important issue is digital trade
we know the u.s want to build a new
digital trade order in this region and
taiwan has always want to be part of it
and just as i mentioned that the u.s
is trying to gain its
importance and also influence in this
region and taiwan is ready to prove that
they are in compliance with their rules
now we know that china views taiwan as
part of its own territory and bristles
at any perceived treatment of taiwan as
a sovereign nation state
what does beijing say about these
planned talks then
well china has always been firmly
opposed to any form of official contacts
between the us and taiwan including the
negotiation of agreements with
sovereign connotations or official
nature
beijing accuses of a u.s plane tricks
over the taiwan issue this time and want
them to stop negotiating and signing
agreements with taiwan
dw soltsung han in taipei so thank you
you